heures avant la réunion avant le paradis
avant le rêve
on va faire une interview cauchemar sur
les stars vous vivez ou dans vos
cauchemars je suis pas de cauchemars
s'avère ouais c'est pas sympa un autre
truc à l'interview cheval mais là on
allait bien c'est une interview à 10h et
les cauchemars et est déjà là ce soir
pourquoi c'est un cauchemar je suis fait
un cauchemar
votre copine elle vous trompe avec qui
dans vos cauchemars
j'ai presque beaucoup rencontres ont pu
noter cauchemar est il va la tabasser
crois que c'est un peu con toi
c'est quoi votre métier joey dans vos
cauchemars font mouche vous écoutez quoi
comme musique dans vos cauchemars stomy
bugzy tu vois que ça bien c'est qu'il
est en tête du top 50 dans vos
cauchemars
vous avez peur de quoi dans vos
cauchemars à yom vous mourrez commandant
vos cauchemars
en héritant du sommet mais si vous
mourez à quel âge dans vos cauchemars à
l'âge de se briser
vous découvrez quoi sur vous dans vos
cauchemars que je ressemblais pas si
vous faites attaquer par quel genre
d'animal dans vos cauchemars à
sarcellois elle ressemble à quoi
l'humanité dans vos cauchemars
c'est parce que ça me ferait de pire
cauchemar ouais vous ayez sur quel
plateau télé dans vos cauchemars talent
chez drucker thaler 1
voilà c'est pas mal il est enjoint de le
dire
plus 3 mai
18 décembre à bercy mais à des
générations celle issue oui tu m'as
goûté équipe fermée mais aucun rôle dans
la main